Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. Harold had fallen, as his valiant brothers had fallen before him. The event too truly showed that England had fallen with the sons of Godwin, that as ever in this age, everything turned on the life of one man, and that the one man who could have guarded and saved England was taken from her. Such being the case, it is from that memorable day that we may fairly date the overthrow, what we know to have been only the imperfect and temporary overthrow of our ancient and free Teutonic
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。想要获取每周独家播客、无广告收听、系列节目抢先收听以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。哈罗德倒下了，正如他英勇的兄弟们此前倒下一样。这一事件确凿地表明，英格兰随着戈德温家族的子嗣一同沦陷了；正如这个时代的常态一样，一切都系于一人之身，而那个本可以守护并拯救英格兰的人却被夺去了生命。既然如此，我们完全可以从那个难忘的日子开始，给我们的古代自由条顿族的颠覆——我们所知道的、对这种颠覆的不完全且暂时的颠覆——一个历史的日期。
England. In the eyes of men of the next generation, that day was the fatal day of England, the day of the sad overthrow of our dear country, the day of her handing over to foreign lords. From that day forward the Normans began to work the will of God upon the folk of England, till they were left in England no chiefs of the land of English blood, till all were brought down to bondage and to sorrow, till it was a shame to be called an Englishman, and the men of England were no more a people. So that was one of the great historians. It was Edward A Freeman.
在下一代人眼中，那一天是英格兰致命的日子，是我们亲爱的国家悲惨覆灭的日子，是她被移交给外国领主的日子。从那天起，诺曼人开始在英格兰人身上践行上帝的意志，直到英格兰再也没有血统纯正的本土首领，直到所有人都沦为奴役与悲伤，直到被称为英格兰人成为了一种耻辱，英格兰人不再是一个民族。所以，这就是其中一位伟大的历史学家，爱德华·A·弗里曼。
It was the man with whom 10 episodes ago we began our account of the Norman Conquest. Now you can't argue with Edward A Freeman because he was Regis Professor of History at Oxford. His book on the Norman Conquest, the history of the Norman Conquest in England, not just the best, but more importantly, the longest history of the Norman Conquest at six volumes published to mark the 800th anniversary. He correctly identified the Normans as the absolute filth of Europe and England and its Teutonic traditions and its traditions of freedom and democracy and love of country. He identified those, Tom, as the motor of all history. And what is more,
这就是我们在10集节目开始时讲述诺曼征服时提到的那个人。现在你无法反驳爱德华·A·弗里曼，因为他是牛津大学的雷吉斯历史学教授。他关于诺曼征服的著作《英国诺曼征服史》，不仅是最好的，更重要的是，它是最长的诺曼征服史，共有六卷，是为了纪念征服800周年而出版的。他正确地指出，诺曼人是欧洲和英格兰绝对的败类，而英格兰及其条顿传统、自由与民主的传统以及对国家的爱，汤姆，他将这些视为所有历史的推动力。而且更重要的是，
he pointed out quite rightly that it doesn't matter about the masses in history and millions of people, it's really about one man and that man is Harold Godwinson, the one man who could have guarded and saved England. This is the best episode of The Rest of City we've ever done. But are you going to now say that this is all Tosh and rubbish? Yeah, so very much your kind of guy. He loves Harold Godwinson, he writes enormously long books. Just go on and on and on and never stop. Yeah, very much your kind of guy. So clearly, he is mourning the death of Harold. He sees the two as being, you know,
他非常正确地指出，历史上的底层群众和数百万人在历史中并不重要，真正重要的是一个人，那个人就是哈罗德·戈德温森，那个唯一能够守护并拯救英格兰的人。这是我们做过的最棒的《历史的 rest》节目。但你现在是要说这都是一派胡言吗？是的，非常符合你的口味。他热爱哈罗德·戈德温森，他写了超级长的书，没完没了、喋喋不休、永不停止。是的，非常符合你的口味。所以很明显，他在哀悼哈罗德的死。他认为这两者是，你知道的，
interfused. Harold is the one man who could have guarded and saved England and now he is dead. So is he right that Hastings was a catastrophe for England? I mean, did it result in the extinction of her ancestral freedoms? Was everything that Anglo-Saxon England had been destroyed at Senlack Hill. Do you know who agreed with this bloke Freeman? The Roundheads, people in the 17th century who believed in the Norman yoke. Dominic, we will be coming to that, we'll be doing a bonus on the way that 1066 and the Norman conquest was interpreted. So there will be more about that
交织在一起的。哈罗德是唯一能够守护并拯救英格兰的人，而现在他死了。那么，他认为黑斯廷斯对英格兰来说是一场灾难，这种说法对吗？我的意思是，这是否导致了她祖传自由的消灭？盎格鲁-撒克逊英格兰的一切都在森拉克山被摧毁了吗？你知道谁同意这个叫弗里曼的家伙的观点吗？圆颅党人，17th世纪相信诺曼枷锁的人。多米尼克，我们接下来会讲到这一点，我们将做一个关于1066年以及诺曼征服如何被解读的特别节目。所以如果你是《历史的 rest》俱乐部的会员，
if you're a member of the Restless History Club. But for now, we're going to try and answer some of those questions that I just put. But a reminder, first of all, of where we ended the previous episode. So it is 1654 on the 14th of October, St. Calixtus's day, 1066, and the sun has just set, and the sun, Dominic, has also set on the forchwins of the Godwins and of England. Oh, terrible. The slopes and the summit of Senlac Hill are piled with the bodies of the dead and the dying and the mud reeks of blood and emptied bowels. Cries fill the darkening twilight and already you've got to imagine pillagers creeping up through the dark, starting to strip corpses of their male shirts, their
会有更多相关内容。但现在，我们要试着回答我刚才提出的一些问题。不过首先，提醒一下我们上一集是在哪里结束的。现在是1654年（译者注：此处播客口误，应为1066年）10月14日，圣卡利克斯特斯日，1066年，太阳刚刚落下，而多米尼克，太阳也落在了戈德温家族和英格兰的财富上。哦，太可怕了。森拉克山的斜坡和山顶堆满了死伤者的尸体，泥土中散发着血腥味和流出的内脏的气味。哭喊声充斥着昏暗的黄昏，你已经可以想象掠夺者在黑暗中蹑手蹑脚地爬上来，开始剥去尸体上的锁子甲、
weapons, their clothes, anything that might be of any value. And the killing is not yet over, even though darkness is now over Sussex, because the English have turned and fled. But this, of course, is when the Norman cavalry comes into its own, because they can pursue the fugitives and hunt them down. You'll be glad to hear Dominic, they don't have it all their own way, because it does seem despite the garbled nature of the various accounts, there seems confusion as to exactly what happens. But it's clear that a body of English warriors, either fugitives or perhaps new arrivals, make a stand perhaps on some ancient earthworks. It's not entirely clear.
武器、衣服，任何可能有价值的东西。杀戮还没有结束，尽管夜幕已经笼罩了苏塞克斯，因为英格兰人已经转身逃跑了。但当然，正是在这个时候，诺曼骑兵发挥了他们的优势，因为他们可以追击逃兵并将他们赶尽杀绝。你会很高兴听到，多米尼克，他们并没有完全为所欲为，因为尽管各种记载语焉不详，对于到底发生了什么似乎存在混淆，但很明显，一队英格兰勇士——无论是逃兵还是新到的援军——在一处古老的土方工事上进行了抵抗，虽然这一点不是很清楚。
And they inflict a number of casualties on the Normans. And there is one report that useless of Beloitne, William's mate, who, according to the earliest account we have, was actually responsible for the death of Harold, that he received a blow between his shoulders that led to blood gushing out from his nose and mouth in a great fountain. That's good news. That's great news. I'm very pleased to hear that. And there are late accounts that report an entire ditch ending up filled with Norman casualties and that it was called the Malthos, so the evil ditch, a great ditch that had
他们给诺曼人造成了相当大的伤亡。有一份报告称，威廉的密友布卢瓦的尤斯塔斯——根据我们现存最早的记载，他实际上是导致哈罗德死亡的责任人——他的两肩之间挨了一记重击，导致鲜血如喷泉般从他的鼻子和嘴里喷涌而出。这真是个好消息。真是太棒的消息了。听到这个我很高兴。还有后来的记载称，最终有一整条沟渠里都填满了诺曼人的尸体，这条沟被称为“马尔托斯”（Malthos），也就是邪恶的沟渠，一条长满荆棘的大沟。
been covered with brambles. So the killing does go on through the night. But when dawn comes on the 15th of October, what it reveals is a spectacle of carnage that is so terrible that even the Normans are kind of stunned by it. A bit like the English after Agincourt, and we should remind ourselves that the English will go on to win a victory over the French in due course. We had the last laugh. William of Pratier writes about the battlefield, I've said that Cael, far and wide the earth was covered with the flower of the English nobility and youth drenched in gore. And William orders the Norman dead to be buried, but does he
所以杀戮整夜都在继续。但当10月15日的黎明到来时，它展现出了一场如此可怕的大屠杀景象，以至于连诺曼人都为之震惊。有点像阿让库尔战役之后的英国人，我们应该提醒自己，英国人终将在适时候战胜法国人。我们笑到了最后。普瓦捷的威廉在谈到战场时写道：“我曾说过，方圆数里的大地都覆盖着被鲜血浸透的英格兰贵族和青年的精英。”威廉下令埋葬死去的诺曼人，但他是否
order the English dead to be buried? Dominic, he does not. He leaves them as food for worms and wolves, birds and dogs, as the Carmen puts it. He does, however, give orders for the bodies of Harold and his two brothers, Geirth and Leifwine, to be found, and they are treated with more respect, although there are so many differing stories about what happens to them and how William chooses to treat them.
下令埋葬死去的英格兰人呢？多米尼克，他没有。正如《卡门诗集》所说，他把他们留作蠕虫和野狼、飞鸟和恶狗的食物。不过，他确实下令寻找哈罗德及其两个兄弟格斯（Geirth）和莱夫温（Leifwine）的尸体，并以更高的礼遇对待他们，尽管关于他们的结局以及威廉如何对待他们，有太多不同的说法。
It's actually, again, very hard to make sense of what may actually have happened. So there is one brilliant late story that Harold's body has been left so mangled that no one can identify it. And so they send for Edith Swanneck, his lover, mistress, concubine, first wife, whatever you want to call her. In the words of the chronicler, she had a more intimate knowledge of his body than anyone else.
实际上，同样很难理清当时究竟发生了什么。因此，有一个精彩的后世传说：哈罗德的尸体被毁容得面目全非，没人能认出他来。于是他们派人去找他的情人、情妇、妾、第一任妻子——随便你怎么称呼她——伊迪丝·天鹅颈（Edith Swanneck）。用编年史家的话来说，她对他的身体比任何人都更熟悉。
If those previous accounts from the last episode are true, then I mean that would avail her nothing. Right. Well, but maybe they found them as well and kind of brought them back and stuck them on. We don't know. The Carmen, which is the source closest in time to Hastings, recounts how William has Harold's body wrapped in purple linen. And then Harold's mother Githa comes and offers to pay William Harold's weight in gold if she can be given the body. Again, a possible classical illusion there to Achilles and Hector and everything.
如果上一集中那些先前的记载是真的，那么这意味着这毫无用处。好吧，但也许他们也找到了尸体，然后把它们拼凑起来安葬了。我们不得而知。《卡门诗集》是距离黑斯廷斯战役时间最近的文献，它记载了威廉用紫色亚麻布包裹哈罗德的尸体，然后哈罗德的母亲吉莎（Githa）前来，提出如果能把尸体交给她，她愿意支付与哈罗德体重相等的黄金。这里再次可能暗指了古典文学中的阿喀琉斯和赫克托耳以及种种传说。
I mean, is it being modeled directly on them? Is Githa thinking of that? We don't know, but according to the Carmen, William doesn't give Githa her son's body and instead he orders it to be buried on top of a cliff looking out over the channel and somebody raises a stone, one of the Normans, and scribes on it, by command of the duke, you repose here King Harold so that you may remain guardian of the shore and ocean. And if that's true, I mean, what's interesting is that William is being described as a duke and Harold is still being described as a king. So I don't
我的意思是，这是在直接模仿他们吗？吉莎是在想着这些吗？我们不得而知，但根据《卡门诗集》，威廉并没有把她儿子的尸体交给吉莎，而是下令把它埋在俯瞰海峡的悬崖顶上。有人——其中一个诺曼人——竖起一块石头，上面刻着：“遵照公爵的命令，你长眠于此，国王哈罗德，愿你继续守护海岸与海洋。”如果这是真的，我的意思是，有趣的是威廉被称为公爵，而哈罗德仍然被称为国王。所以我不
think that would have lasted very long. There are other accounts of what happens to Harold's body. So a late account says it was given to Gither, who buried it in Waltham Abbey in Essex, which Harold had refounded under his own kind of patronage in 1060. So that's, I mean, we don't know. And there is a modern theory that it's in the Sussex port of Bosom, which had been Harold's birthplace and is shown in the Bayeux tapestry. Harold sails from it for his disastrous trip to France. So within an arrow's flight of Keith Richards' house in West Wittering. That's the version I like to believe. Yeah, and I imagine Keith Richards would be interested in this. Keith Richards loves this history. So he'd have been all over the fact that in 1954, an Anglo-Saxon coffin was found in the
认为这种情况会持续很久。关于哈罗德尸体的去向还有其他说法。因此，一份后来的记载称，尸体被交给了吉莎，她将之安葬在埃塞克斯郡的沃尔瑟姆 abbey（Waltham Abbey），那是哈罗德在1060年以自己的名义重建的。所以，我的意思是，我们并不清楚。还有一个现代理论认为它在苏塞克斯港口博森（Bosom），那是哈罗德的出生地，也在贝叶挂毯上有显示。哈罗德从那里起航前往法国，踏上了他那灾难性的旅程。所以，距离基思·理查兹（Keith Richards）在西威特林的房子只有一箭之遥。这就是我愿意相信的版本。是的，我想基思·理查兹会对这个感兴趣。基思·理查兹热爱这段历史。所以他肯定会全面了解1066年（译者注：原文为1954，系口误，可能指考古发现）在那里的教堂发现了一具盎格鲁-撒克逊棺材的事。这显然是一具威风凛凛的战士的骨骼。谁知道呢？我想起基思·理查兹，是因为在我看来他非常具有盎格鲁-撒克逊男人的气质，而不是诺曼人。是的。我认为米克·贾格尔更像诺曼人。完全同意。
church there. And it apparently was the skeleton of a formidable looking warrior. So who knows? I think of Keith Richards because he seems to me very much an Anglo-Saxon man, not a Norman. Yes. I think Mick Jagger more of a Norman. Agreed.
对金钱非常感兴趣。是的，绝对如此。眼神冰冷。眼神冰冷。基思·理查兹绝对是一个在11世纪会留着一撇极佳胡须的男人。有诺曼人的记载称，英格兰人在黑斯廷斯战役的前夜喝得酩酊大醉。太棒了，你看。这很有滚石乐队的风格。无论如何，不管这些故事如何，我们其实并不知道哪一个才是真的。不可避免地还有一种传言称哈罗德在战役中幸存下来并隐居做了一名隐士，这在类似情况下很常见，但不管真相如何，他已经不在了。而大家在这个时候大概都在问的重大问题是，这是否意味着战争已经结束？没错，因为战争还可以继续，对吧？我的意思是，威廉早期的英格兰领地只有微乎其微的一点点，
Very interested in money. Yeah, exactly. Cold-eyed. Cold-eyed. Keith Richards very much a man who would have sported an excellent moustache in the 11th century. There are Norman accounts that the English on the night before Hastings spend it getting wasted. Brilliant, there you go. That's quite rolling stones. Anyway, however, all these stories, we don't really know which of them is true. There's inevitably an also report that Harold survived the battle and became a hermit, which is traditional in such cases, but whatever the truth, he is gone. And the big question that everyone presumably is asking at this point is, does this mean the war is over? Right, because it could continue, right? I mean, William Early has the tiniest, tiniest bit of England,
只有一个微小的立足点，而英格兰非常广阔，它有着高度复杂的国家机器，拥有大量人口，并且拥有尚武的传统。所以为什么，这是一个有趣的问题，为什么诺曼征服基本上，为什么这场游戏就这么结束了？好吧，我们也许会嘲笑维多利亚时代的人执着于伟大人物、伟大人物的命运影响民族进程的观点。我认为在这种情况下，他的看法并没有错。我认为，假使英格兰还剩下任何有能力继续抵抗威廉、并因此顺理成章被接受为国王的人，这场战争绝对还可以继续打下去并取得胜利。所以你需要一个有能力且能作为合法国王统治的人。但问题是，这样的人实际上并不存在。所以格斯和莱夫温都
a little foothold, and there's a lot of England, and England has a very sophisticated state, and it's got a lot of people, and it's got a martial tradition. So why does, this is an interesting question, why does the Norman Conquest basically, why is this game over? Well, we laugh perhaps at the way that Victorians insist on, you know, great men, the fate of great men affecting the course of nations. I think in this case, he's not far wrong. I think the war absolutely could have still been prosecuted and won had there been anyone left in England competent to continue the resistance to William and by implication be accepted as as King. So you need someone who's competent and can rule as a legitimate King. But the problem is is there isn't really anyone. So Gareth and Laefion are
死了。埃德温和莫卡，如果他们参加了这场战役，没有人提起过。他们当然也没有留下来。无论他们是从黑斯廷斯赶来还是从中部地区赶来，他们都去了伦敦，救出了他们的姐姐、哈罗德的遗孀，并把她带到了切斯特。还有埃德加·埃瑟林（Edgar Atheling），他是忏悔者爱德华的曾侄孙。你知道，他血管里流淌着西撒克逊诸王之血。盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史告诉我们，约克大主教阿尔德雷德（Archbishop Aildred）以及伦敦人民希望拥立他为国王，这确实也是他与生俱来的权利。但是，你知道的，他还是个十几岁的少年，没有任何自己的军事资源，而他现在面对的是欧洲最优秀的
dead. Edwin and Morka, if they were at the battle, nobody mentions it. They certainly haven't hung around. Whether they're coming from Hastings or whether they're coming from the Midlands, they go to London and they rescue their sister, Harald's widow, and take her away up to Chester. There is Edgar Atheling, who is Edward the Confessor's great nephew. You know, he has the blood of the West Saxon kings in his veins. And we're told in the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle Archbishop Aildred, so that's the Archbishop of York, and the people of London wished to have him as King, as indeed was his right by birth. But, you know, he's a teenager, he lacks any military resources of his own whatsoever, and he is now facing the best
将领，刚刚赢得了一场非常非常血腥的战役。所以当弗里曼说“那个唯一能够守护并拯救英格兰的人被夺去了生命，即哈罗德”时，我的意思是，他并没有夸大其词。如果哈罗德幸存下来，即使是在黑斯廷斯的失利也可能，你知道的，未必是致命的。快问一个问题。这难道不是埃德温和莫卡站出来宣称他们在历史中的地位的时刻吗？而实际上他们没有。这是他们的机会。也许吧，但他们没有。我的意思是，这才是显而易见的事实。据推测他们没有这样做，是因为他们觉得自己没有后盾。好吧。那么这是否意味着威廉已经获胜了？
general in Europe, who's just won a very, very bloody battle. So I think that when Freeman says the one man who could have guarded and saved England was taken from her, namely Harold, I mean, he's not exaggerating really. Had Harold survived, even the loss at Hastings might have been, you know, might not have been fatal. Quick question. Is this not the moment where Edward and Moorcar could step up and claim their place in history? And actually they don't. And this was their opportunity. Maybe, but they don't. I mean, that's the salient thing. And presumably they don't because they feel they haven't got backing. Okay. Does this mean then that William has won?
同样，未必如此，因为正如你所说，英格兰太庞大了。它拥有巨大的人力资源。与本土英格兰国王所能动员的人力相比，威廉的军队规模很小，而且比登陆时更小了，因为他们在伟大的战役中牺牲了许多人。他在英格兰仍然没有公开的盟友，而且当然，冬天即将来临。所以他的处境仍然不够稳固，实际上他必须夺取对王国的控制权，这意味着在冬天来临之前，必须得到贤人会议（Witan）、王国的显贵以及主要的主教和大主教的承认，否则他就麻烦大了。那他该怎么做？首先，他坐在那里等待贤人会议向他献上王冠，一周过去了，
Again, not necessarily, because as you said, England is huge. It has immense resources of manpower. William's force relative to the manpower available to a native English king is small and smaller than it was when it landed because they've, you know, lots of people have died in the great battle. He still has no declared allies in England and of course, winter is closing in. So he's still not in a secure position and effectively he has to seize command of the kingdom, which means being recognised by the Witan, by the magnates and the leading bishops and archbishops of the kingdom before winter sets in or he's in real trouble. So what does he do? First of all, he sits and waits for the Witan to offer him the crown and a week passes,
两周过去了，贤人会议仍然没有任何动静。于是他决定：“去他的，我可不受这气。”于是他拔营起寨，向东朝多佛进发。在路上，他确保向英格兰人宣告反对他的下场将会是什么。他们路过了沿海小镇罗姆尼（Romney），那里的一些诺曼船只曾因迷航而靠岸，当地人屠杀了他们。威廉现在通过将该镇付之一炬，对他们进行了可怕的报复。然后他向多佛推进，多佛在看到他的军队时便投降了。显然，尽管诺曼人在黑斯廷斯遭受了惨重的伤亡，他们仍然是一支非常非常具有威慑力的力量。威廉在那里停留了一个星期，据一个消息来源称是三个星期，用来改善其
two weeks pass, and still there is nothing from the Witan. So he decides, hang this, I'm not putting up with this. So he raises camp and he heads eastwards for Dover. And on the way, So he raises camp and he heads eastwards for Dover and on the way he makes sure to proclaim to the English what the fruits of opposing him will be. So they go past the coastal town of Romney where some of the Norman ships had landed by mistake and the locals had slaughtered them. And William now exacts a terrible vengeance on them by putting the town to the torch. He then advances on Dover, which surrenders at the very site of his army. And so clearly, despite all the casualties that the Normans had suffered at Hastings, they're still a very, very intimidating site. And William stays there maybe for a week, one source says for three weeks, improving its
防御工事，获取增援。当然，多佛是，你知道的——那是最短的海峡渡口，因此对于一个入侵英格兰的征服者来说，这是一个非常有用且需要控制的据点。在确保了多佛的安全之后，他又去夺取了两个至关重要的战果。其中第一个是坎特伯雷，该城亲自向他投降。威廉正从多佛经坎特伯雷向伦敦进军。而坎特伯雷当然是坎特伯雷大主教的驻地，因此是英格兰神圣性的核心焦点。他还得到了温彻斯特，该城落入了他派出的轻骑兵纵队手中。温彻斯特，你知道的，它是阿尔弗雷德大帝的首都。虽然它作为首都的地位已被伦敦稍微取代，但对西撒克逊人来说，它仍然是一个非常非常重要的地点。
fortifications, getting reinforcements. Dover, of course, is, you know, I mean, it's the shortest crossing, so a very useful stronghold for an invader of England to control. And then having secured Dover, he then goes on to secure two crucial prizes. So the first of these is Canterbury, which submits to him in person. So William is marching from Dover to Canterbury towards London. And Canterbury, of course, is the seat of the Archbishop of Canterbury. So the great focus of English sacrality. And he also gets Winchester, which falls to a flying column of men that he sent. And Winchester, you know, it's the capital of Alfred the Great. It's been slightly displaced
因此，控制这个地方是一个非常好的征兆，而更具重大意义的是，正是在坎特伯雷和温彻斯特向他投降的时候，消息传到了威廉耳中：埃德加·埃瑟林被贤人会议推选为国王。这是一个在诺曼征服的故事中经常被忽略、在许多记载中几乎未被提及的时刻，那就是我们突然有了一个替代的国王。是的，你刚才说他只是个青少年。
as the capital by London, but it's still a very, very significant place for the West Saxons. And so to control that, that's a very good sign and it's all the more significance because it is now, as both Canterbury and Winchester submit to him, that news reaches William that Edgar Atholing has been elected King by the Witton. So that's a moment that's often elided in the stories of the Norman conquest that's barely mentioned in a lot of accounts, which is that suddenly we do have an alternative king. And yes, you said he was a teenager.
话虽如此，青少年以前也曾多次赢得王位，埃德蒙·红耳王（Edmund Ironside）在与克努特（Canute）作战时还是个青少年，而威廉在平定诺曼底的抵抗时也是个青少年。因此，收听节目的许多听众可能会想：“这货是谁？我从来没听说过这家伙。”我的意思是，别假装他是这个故事里的重要角色，因为我从来没听说过他。这也是那只没有叫的狗。
That said, teenagers have often won thrones before and Edmund Ironside had been a teenager when he'd been fighting Canute. And William had been a teenager when stamping down resistance in Normandy. So a lot of listeners to this would be like, well, who's this bloke? I've never heard of this bloke. I mean, don't try and pretend he's a big player in this story, because I've never heard of him. And again, it's a dog that doesn't bark.
我的意思是，埃德加·埃瑟林在伦敦，而伦敦是重中之重，是首都。所以，事实上，当威廉从坎特伯雷向伦敦进军并要求投降时，伦敦并没有投降。那么为什么这个故事没有下文呢？为什么埃德加·埃瑟林没有坚守、集结军队，然后接下来的10年里爆发埃德加·埃瑟林与威廉之间的大内战呢？所以他是那种模棱两可的国王之一。我想他有点像是盎格鲁-撒克逊历史上的简·格雷女士（Lady Jane Grey），你永远不确定是否应该把他列入英格兰国王的名单中。
I mean, Edgar Affling is in London, which is the great prize, which is the capital. So, and actually when William marches on London from Canterbury and says surrender, London does not surrender. So why does this story not go anywhere? Why doesn't Edgar Atheling hold out, raise an army, and then the next 10 years be a great civil war between Edgar Atheling and William? So he's one of those kind of ambivalent kings. I suppose he's kind of the Anglo-Saxon Lady Jane Grey, you're never quite sure whether to include him in the list of English kings or not. I
我的意思是，我认为答案显然是他缺乏在战场上与威廉抗衡的 charisma（个人魅力）和资源，这就是为什么当威廉向伦敦进军时，他只能躲在城墙后保全自己。威廉占领了萨瑟克（Southwark），即伦敦桥以南泰晤士河的南岸地带，并没有试图强渡伦敦桥进入伦敦，但他确保将萨瑟克付之一炬，以便伦敦所有围绕在埃德加身边的人都能亲眼目睹这位新国王根本无力抵抗威廉的推进。随后，他继续向西进军，深入韦塞克斯（Wessex）的核心地带，并采取了我们之前引用过、但我想再次引用的策略。普瓦捷的威廉这样描述
mean, I think the answer is that clearly he lacks the charisma and the resources to meet William in the field, which is why when William marches on London, he stays immune within the walls. William occupies Southwark, so the southern stretches of the Thames south of London Bridge, does not try and force London Bridge and enter London, but he makes sure to put Sothek to the torch so that everyone in London who are around Edgar can witness the fact that this new king is powerless to resist William's advance. And he then carries on heading westwards into the heartlands of Wessex and he adopts this policy that we've already quoted, but I'll quote it again. William of Poitiers describing the
诺曼人的战争方式：通过毁灭庄稼、田地和领地来制造恐惧，攻占途经的所有城镇，并在其中驻扎守军；简而言之，无情地攻击一个特定的地区并将其卷入无穷无尽的麻烦之中。这就是现在降临到韦塞克斯的命运，当然，这里是英格兰的心脏地带。这是由阿尔弗雷德和阿特尔斯坦（Athelstan）统治过的王国。这里也是戈德温家族的大本营。哈罗德曾是韦塞克斯伯爵。因此，威廉正在让英格兰人难堪，让他们明白英格兰王国的跳动心脏现在归他所有，他可以随心所欲地处置。于是他一路向西残毁，直达牛津郡的沃林福德（Wallingford）。正如沃林福德这个名字所暗示的那样，
Norman way of war, striking fear by laying waste to the crops, fields and domains, capturing all the towns that lay in his path, putting garrisons in them, in short, to assault a given region relentlessly and engulf it in a great multitude of troubles. And this is now the fate that is visited on Wessex, which is the heartland of England, of course. It's the kingdom that had been ruled by Alfred and by Athelstan. And it was the great stronghold of the Godwins. Harold had been Earl of Wessex. And so William is making, he is rubbing the noses of the English in the fact that the heartbeat of the English kingdom is now his to do with as he pleases. And so he ravages the whole
它是泰晤士河上一个有防御工事的渡口。阿尔弗雷德曾在它周围建造了城墙。它是他的防御性堡垒（burh）之一，但当地的塞尔恩（Thane）向威廉投降了。你知道的，他只是瞥了一眼率领军队的威廉，然后就说：“嘿，请进。你知道的，我才不在这里死守呢。”于是威廉占领了沃林福德，并在那里接受了一次关键的
way westwards as far as Wallingford in Oxfordshire. And as the name of Wallingford suggests, it's a fortified ford across the Thames. Alfred had built walls around it. It was one of his kind of fortified burrs, but the local Thane surrenders it to William. You know, he's just one glimpse of William at the head of his army. And he's, Hey, please come in. You know, I'm not, I'm not hanging around here. And so William occupies Wallingford and it is there that he receives a key
投降，这就是坎特伯雷大主教斯蒂甘德（Stigand）。这一定是一个重大的时刻，因为斯蒂甘德带来了英国教会的权威和合法性。嗯，记住斯蒂甘德是一个非常具有争议的人物。他同时兼任温彻斯特主教这一事实，曾被用作要求向威廉颁发教皇旗帜的理由之一。因此，深知自己处于威廉打击目标之中的斯蒂甘德选择投降，我认为具有双重重要性。正如你所说，他代表了英国教会，
submission and this is Stigand, the Archbishop of Canterbury. That must be a big moment because Stigand brings the authority and the legitimacy of the English church. Well, bear in mind that Stigand is a very controversial figure. The fact that he is simultaneously the Bishop of Winchester has been used as one of the reasons for why William should be given a papal banner. So the fact that Stigand, who knows that he is in the crosshairs of William, that he chooses to surrender is I think doubly significant. As you say, he represents the English church,
但同时他也是一个有着充分理由继续战斗的人物。然而他没有，他基本上算是妥协了。不过埃德加依然不见踪影。于是威廉继续他的大肆破坏，从沃林福德出发，他又折向东朝伦敦进军，从北部对该城形成合围之势。局势发展的消息自然传到了伦敦。所有人都陷入了绝对的恐慌之中。难民们逃离诺曼骑士的推进，他们带来了入侵者施加的所有恐怖暴行的故事。人们恳求埃德温和莫卡行军保卫他们。他们拒绝了，显然整个局势
but also he's a figure who has every reason to try and continue the fight. And he hasn't, he's basically kind of given in. Edgar though, still no sign of him. And so William continues with his ravaging and from Wallingford, he now turns back eastwards towards London, kind of closing in on the city from the north. And the news of what is happening, of course, reaches London. Everyone is thrown into a state of absolute terror. You've got refugees fleeing the advance of the Norman Knights. They are bringing tales of all the horrors that are being inflicted by the invaders. People beg Edwin and Morka to march and defend them. They refuse and clearly the whole situation
已经无可救药，埃德加基本上意识到自己没有坚守的希望。于是他、约克大主教阿尔德雷德、埃德温、莫卡，所有人都聚集在一起，列队前往赫特福德郡的伯克姆斯特德（Berkensted），威廉的军队就在那里扎营。那里没有堡垒，所以他们正忙着建造一个“莫特”（mot），即一个巨大的土丘，他们将在其上建造一个“贝利”（bailey），即一座堡垒。你今天依然可以看到它。事实上，我的钓鱼教练杰夫就住在那里，他为那里的莫特和贝利城堡感到非常自豪。很高兴提到杰夫。总之，埃德加·埃瑟林和伦敦的所有显贵、埃德温和莫卡、约克
is hopeless and Edgar essentially realizes he has no prospect of holding out. And so he, Eildred, the Archbishop of York, Edwin, Morka, they all congregate and they go in procession to Birkensted in Hertfordshire where William's army has camped. There isn't a burr there and so they're busy building a mot, great mound of earth on which they will build a bailey, a fort. You can still see it to this day. And in fact, Jeff, my fishing coach, lives there and he's very proud of the motte and bailey there. So good to get Jeff in. Anyway, so Edgar Atheling and all the chief men of London, Edwin and Morka, the Archbishop
大主教，都来到伯克姆斯特德拜见威廉。盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史以赤裸裸的蔑视语气描述了他们的投降：“在遭受了最大的破坏之后，他们出于无奈才投降的”——这就是威廉所造成的种种破坏——“而且他们没有早点这么做真是大愚蠢，因为上帝由于我们的罪孽而不会让事情变好。”他们交出人质，向他宣誓效忠。而他则承诺会成为他们温和的封君。然而与此同时，他们洗劫了他们踏过的一切地方。他们指的是诺曼人。
of York, they all come to William at Birkenstead. And the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle describes their submission in tones of naked contempt. They submitted out of necessity after most damage had been done, so that's all the ravaging that William has inflicted. And it was a great piece of folly that they had not done it earlier, since God would not make things better because of our sins. And they gave hostages and swore oaths to him. And he promised them that he would be a gracious liege lord. And yet in the meantime, they ravaged all that they overran. They being the Normans.
他们指的是诺曼人。所以在我们继续讲伦敦的投降之前，先问一个简单的问题。显然，埃德温和莫卡在哈拉尔·哈德拉达的战役中战败了，听众们可能还记得。埃德加·埃瑟林显然就是个废物。他根本没有杀手的本能。如果这三个人中有一个人是洛根·罗伊（Logan Roy）所说的“严肃的人”——也就是说，他们能看清机会并说：“好吧，我就是这个人，团结英格兰人民，我们要跟这家伙战斗，真的，你知道的，我们要把他驱逐出我们的海岸，让我们大干一场吧，就像埃德蒙·红耳王那样”——那么，诺曼征服有没有可能……威廉会输掉第二场战役吗？我认为他们必须是一个非常严肃的人，因为威廉他是一个非常、非常严肃的人。我的意思是，他完全冷酷无情。他完全坚信自己行为的正义性，并觉得上帝赋予了他全权，让他不惜一切代价迫使英格兰人投降。当你面对这样一个既有能力、
They being the Normans. So just a quick question before we move on to the submission of London. Clearly Edwin and Moorcar, they'd lost that battle at Zahraud Hardrada, listeners may remember. Edgar Atheling is clearly just a bit of a waste of space. He just hasn't got the killer instincts. Had one of those three men be what Logan Roy would call a serious person, i.e. they would see the opportunity and they would say, right, I'm the man, rally
背后又有如此强大战争机器的人时，正如我所说，你真的、真的必须是一个严肃的人。我认为很明显，埃德温和莫卡大概都在镜子里照了照，然后想：“我真的不认为自己有这个能力。”所以问题就在这里：爱德华·奥古斯都·弗里曼说得完全对，个人在历史中确实很重要，而这就是一个缺乏这样的人物对英格兰造成重大影响的例子。不过无论如何，我打断了你的叙述。没有，因为我认为你切中了从英格兰人角度来看这场局势的最大悲剧。如果有人能够指挥英格兰至今毫无疑问仍然拥有的资源，他们本可以战斗。但因为他们没有，因为威廉拥有一套经过千锤百炼的战役战略计划，而英格兰人从未见过这种阵仗。他们从未遇到过配备了建造城堡能力的重装骑兵。而这当然正是哈罗德一直非常担心的事。正是这导致他做出了最终灾难性的决定，前往黑斯廷斯迎战诺曼人。但哈罗德理解了英格兰人所面临的威胁，我不认为其他人意识到了这一点。因此，我认为当伦敦不断收到城镇和农场起火的报告时，其影响……
the people of England, we're going to fight this guy and really, you know, we're going to drive him from our shores and let's do this, Edmund Ironside, let's say. Is it plausible the Norman Conquest might, you know, William could have lost a second battle. I think they would have had to be a very serious man because William, he is a very, very serious man. I mean, he is completely ruthless. He is completely convinced of his own justice and he feels that he has a license from God to do whatever it takes to force the English to submit. And when you're up against someone as able as that, and with
我的意思是，这就像是一种“世界大战”的状况，恐怖的入侵者在四周到处焚烧。这些比哈拉尔·哈德拉达的军队更加强大、更加可怕。所以你可以理解为什么他们会选择投降。当然，随着伦敦和埃德加·埃瑟林的投降，我们迎来了1066年——这个最宿命的一年——的高潮。威廉实现了他的既定目标。在冬天恶化之前，他夺取了王国的心脏。到了圣诞节时——圣诞节当然是查理曼大帝加冕的日子——威廉已经准备好为自己加冕了。因此他在圣诞节前几天进入伦敦，现场有庞大的军事存在，伦敦没有任何人会怀疑他们生活在一个被占领的城市里，威廉立即不可避免地命令在泰晤士河畔城市东南角的城墙旁建造一座城堡，这座城堡就是我们今天所知的伦敦塔。
as formidable a war machine behind him, I mean, as I say, you've really, really got to be a serious person. And I think it's clear that Edwin and Moorkeh both probably look in the mirror and think, I don't really think I've got what it takes. So here's the thing, Edward Augustus Freeman was quite right. Individuals do matter in history and this is an example where the lack of such an individual really matters for England. But anyway, I took you off the narrative. No, because I think you home in from the English point of view, the great tragedy of the situation. They could have fought if someone had been there to command the resources that England
当然，不仅是隐藏在罗马城墙背后的伦敦落入了网中，忏悔者爱德华在伦敦西部建造的巨大宫殿群也是如此。这不仅是一座宫殿，还是一座大教堂或修道院，即威斯敏斯特（Westminster）。正是1066年圣诞节那天在威斯敏斯特大教堂，威廉加冕了，距离哈罗德推测在那里加冕几乎正好过了一年，一切
still undoubtedly has. But because they don't, because William has a strategy, a campaigning plan that is tried and tested and the English don't know what's hit them. They have never come up across armoured horsemen with the capacity to build castles. And this of course was what Harold had been so worried about. It's what had led him to make the ultimately disastrous decision to go and fight the Normans in front of Hastings. But Harold had understood what the English were facing. I don't think anyone else had. And so I think the impact of, you know, reports coming into London of towns and farms on fire.
似乎都彻底改变了。因此，在大教堂外威廉加冕的时候，站岗的是一排排穿着锁子甲、说法语的外国士兵，他们守卫着英格兰国王的加冕礼。在大教堂内，有另一个法国式的创新：约克大主教和一位诺曼主教先后走上前，询问会众是否愿意接受威廉为国王——约克大主教阿尔德雷德用英语，而法国主教则用法语。教堂内和教堂外传来了会众热烈回应的欢呼声，据报道，这导致了混乱。普瓦捷的威廉声称，站在大教堂外的卫兵将这种欢呼声误解为英格兰人的背叛。
I mean, it's a kind of war of the world situation, terrifying invaders burning all around. These are more formidable, more terrifying even than Harold Ardrada's army. So you can see why they would submit. And of course with the submission of London and of Edgar Atheling, we come to the climax of 1066 of this most fateful of years. William has achieved what he set out to achieve. He has secured the heart of the kingdom before winter sets in very badly. And by the time it is Christmas, so Christmas was the day that Charlemagne, of course, had been crowned, William is ready to be crowned himself. So he enters London a few days before Christmas, there is a massive military presence, no one
我的意思是，同样可能的是——事实上很有可能——他们本来就已经在胡作非为，他们只是开始攻击人们了。当然，无论出于什么原因，威斯敏斯特大教堂周围都发生了掠夺和房屋焚烧事件。这是一个极其不祥且戏剧性的场景。极其不祥，会众们急忙跑出去帮忙扑灭大火。奥德里克·维塔利斯（Audreic Fetalis）——这位在诺曼底写作的英格尔-诺曼（Anglo-Norman）历史学家——对此事评价道，只有主教、神职人员以及僧侣们惊恐地留在圣坛前，但仪式仍在继续，威廉被涂抹圣油、加冕，然后坐在他的王座上，尽管长椅几乎空无一人，大教堂门外还传来了火焰噼啪作响的尖叫声。
in London can have any doubt that they are living in a city under occupation, and immediately and inevitably William orders the construction of a castle on the southeast corner of the city walls by the Thames, and this castle is the castle that today we know as the Tower of London. But of course, it's not only London itself behind its Roman walls that has fallen into his hands, so too has the great palace complex built by Edward the Confessor to the west of London. And it's not just a palace, it's a minster or an abbey, so Westminster. And it is in Westminster Abbey on Christmas day that William is crowned, almost a year since Harold had presumably been crowned there, and everything
但他可以坐在那里想：“好吧，你知道的，我的这场豪赌，胜算曾如此渺茫，但我的赌博成功了。”他不再是一个公爵了，他现在是一位受过圣油涂抹的国王。当他的追随者向他致敬时——既然他现在已经加冕，他们就像这样做了——他们使用的词句基本上将他置于与拉丁基督教世界仅有的另外两位统治者同等的水平上，那就是皇帝和法兰西国王。所以这个男人从一个公爵变成了一位受膏国王，他的追随者用这些辞藻向他欢呼，称他为最平和的威廉、伟大而赐予和平的国王、受上帝加冕的生命与胜利者。因此，威廉受到这样的欢呼，我的意思是，这是征服的终极成果。然而奇怪的是——我们谈到了黑斯廷斯是否彻底结束了盎格鲁-撒克逊英格兰——奇怪的是，威廉在威斯敏斯特大教堂的加冕礼既是延续的象征，也是断裂的象征。请解释一下。
seems utterly changed. So outside the Abbey, as William is being crowned, you have ranks of mailed French speaking foreigners standing guard over the coronation of King of England. Inside the Abbey you have another French innovation, the Archbishop of York and then a Norman Bishop both step forward and ask the congregation if they will accept William as King, Eldred, the Archbishop of York in English of course, but the French Bishop in French. And there is a great answering acclamation from the congregation in the Abbey and outside the Abbey, this results, it is reported in chaos. William of Poitiers claims that the guards who are standing outside the Abbey interpret the acclamation as English treachery.
好吧，让我们看看威廉在想什么。奥德里克·维塔利斯告诉我们，当他被祝圣时——也就是当他被涂抹圣油时——他剧烈地颤抖。人们常常想知道为什么。许多人猜测，也许他是在反思自己为了夺取王位所做的一切。
I mean, it's equally possible, in fact, probable that they've already, they're just going on the rampage, that they've just begun attacking people. And certainly, whatever the reason for it, there is looting and there is burning of houses around Westminster Abbey. An incredibly ominous and dramatic scene. Very ominous and members of the congregation hurry out to help fight the flames. And Audreic Fetalis, who is this Anglo-Norman, identifies as English writing in Normandy. He says of this, that only the bishops and clergy along with the monks stayed terrified in front of the altar, but the service still goes ahead and William is anointed, crowned, and then he sits on his throne, even though the pews are pretty much empty and there are screams of the crackling of flames coming from outside the Abbey doors.
他知道自己要下地狱了。也许大教堂门外闪烁的火焰只会加剧这种感觉。但我认为这不太可能，我不认为威廉是在其胜利的巅峰时刻会有所怀疑的人，因为我更倾向于认为，在上帝赋予他的责任面前，他感到了敬畏——面对在种种逆境中上帝托付到他手中的责任。所以他是一个征服者，他后来被称为征服者，但他并没有作为征服者加冕。我认为，在威廉自己的看法中，他作为忏悔者爱德华的继承人加冕这一意义，往往被掩盖了。因为那场加冕礼的一切都在宣告，他加冕不是凭借他用宝剑赢得的胜利，而是凭权利。
But he could sit there and think, well, you know, my gamble, the odds were so immense, but his gamble has succeeded. He's no longer a Duke. He is now an anointed King. And when his followers salute him, as they do now that he's been crowned, they do so in terms that place him on a level basically with only two other rulers in Latin Christendom, and that is the emperor and the king of France. So this man has gone from being a duke to being an anointed king whose followers hail him in these terms, to the most serene William, the great and peace-giving king, crowned by God, life, and victory. So for William to be hailed in this way, I mean, it is the ultimate fruit of conquest. And yet the weird thing is, so we talked about whether Hastings finishes Anglo-Saxon England
他是合法的继承人，不仅是忏悔者爱德华的继承人，也是一直追溯到阿尔弗雷德、直至库迪克（Kurdic）的国王世系的合法继承人，他真正是英格兰受膏的国王。因此，这场加冕礼在由忏悔者爱德华建造的威斯敏斯特大教堂举行。加冕仪式——尽管有一些源自法国习俗的插曲——但总体而言，它正是当年埃格尔在我们的故事开头被加冕时，在巴斯（Bath）举行的祝圣仪式。他被祝圣为盎格鲁-撒克逊基（Anglo-Saxoniki），即盎格鲁-撒克逊人的统治者。这是一个可以追溯到阿尔弗雷德的公式。
off for good. The weird thing is, is that William's coronation in Westminster Abbey is actually a symbol of continuity as well as of rupture. Explain that. Well, let's see what William is thinking. So Audrait Vitalis tells us that as he's being consecrated, so as he's being anointed, he trembled violently. And people have often wondered why. And lots of people have suggested that perhaps he was reflecting on everything he'd done to seize the throne.
所以他作为英格兰盎格鲁-撒克逊人的国王加冕。顺便明确一下，他们绝对使用了“盎格鲁-撒克逊人”这个词。所以如果有任何非常激动的美国学者在听，请听清这些词并反思你们的行为。我认为你抓住这一点是正确的。我的意思是，这与我们对诺曼征服意义的理解并不吻合——威廉是以盎格鲁-撒克逊人的国王身份加冕的。这是因为，当然，1066年可能是英格兰历史上最深刻的断裂。这是一个充满入侵、流血、绝对是征服的年份。但这也是以非常公开、非常响亮地坚持“既有延续又有断裂”而告终的一年。尽管显而易见的是，威廉的统治依赖于装甲武力——大教堂外面那些士兵所做的正是这个——但它也同样依赖于他对新王国历史和传统的尊重。因为正是这段历史、正是这些传统赋予了他作为一位受圣油祝圣的国王的地位。如果他践踏了这些，那么这种地位就毫无意义。对于威廉本人而言，这显然是一个很难把握的平衡。我认为我们无法真正为1066年——这个非凡的一年——的叙事画上句号，如果不看看在1066年之后的岁月里，威廉
He knows he's going to hell. And maybe the flickering of flames outside the doors of the abbey only enhance that. But I think it's unlikely, I don't think William is the kind of person to have doubts at the climactic moment of his triumph, because I think it's much more likely that he is feeling awe before the God-given scale of his responsibilities that God has entrusted into his hands against all the odds. So he is a conqueror, he will come to be known as the conqueror, but he's not being crowned as a conqueror. I think that the sense in which, in William's own opinion, he is being crowned as the heir of Edward the Confessor, tends to be obscured. Because everything about that
他知道自己要下地狱。也许修道院门外闪烁的火苗更加深了这种感觉。但我认为这不太可能，威廉不会在胜利的巅峰时刻产生怀疑，因为我更倾向于认为，在上帝赋予他的、超越一切艰难险阻的崇高责任面前，他感到了敬畏。因此他是一位征服者，后人也会称他为征服者，但他并非以征服者的身份加冕。我认为，在威廉自己的认知中，他作为忏悔者爱德华继承人的身份加冕这一事实往往被忽视了。因为这一切都
coronation is proclaiming that he is being crowned not by virtue of the victories he's won with his sword, but by right. That he is the legitimate heir, not just to Edward the Confessor, but to the line of kings that stretches back to Alfred all the way to Kurdic, that he is truly the anointed king of England. So it's being held in Westminster Abbey, built by Edward the Confessor. The coronation ritual, although there are a few interpolations that come from French practice, in the main, it's exactly the consecration rite that had been staged at Bath when Edgar had been crowned right back at the beginning of our story. And he is consecrated as the ruler of the Anglo-Saxoniki, the Anglo-Saxons. And this is a formula that goes back to Alfred.
加冕礼都在宣告：他的加冕不是凭借长剑赢得的胜利，而是凭借正当权利。他是合法的继承人，不仅是忏悔者爱德华的继承人，也是追溯到阿尔弗雷德乃至库尔迪克的历代国王的继承人，他是真正受膏的英格兰国王。所以典礼在忏悔者爱德华修建的威斯敏斯特修道院举行。加冕仪式的核心——尽管其中有一些来自法国习俗的插曲——依然是当年埃德加在故事开端于巴斯举行加冕时完全相同的祝圣仪式。他被奉为盎格鲁-萨克逊人（Anglo-Saxoniki）的统治者，这是一个可以追溯到阿尔弗雷德时期的公式。
So he is being crowned as King of the Anglo-Saxons of England. Just to be clear, they absolutely use the term Anglo-Saxons. So if there's any very excitable American academics listening, listen to those words and reflect on your behavior. And I think you're right to fix on that. I mean, it doesn't gel with our sense of what the Norman conquest is about, that William is being crowned as King of the Anglo-Saxons. And that's because of course 1066 is probably the profoundest rupture in English history. It's a year of invasion, of bloodshed, absolutely,
因此，他是作为英格兰盎格鲁-萨克逊人的国王加冕的。顺便澄清一下，他们绝对使用了“盎格鲁-萨克逊人”这个词。所以如果有任何情绪激动的美国学者在听的话，请听清这些词并反思你们的行为。我认为你抓住这一点是正确的。我的意思是，这与我们对诺曼征服本质的理解并不契合，即威廉是以盎格鲁-萨克逊国王的身份加冕的。这是因为1066年无疑是英格兰历史上最深远的断裂。这是充满入侵与流血的一年，绝对是
of conquest. But it is also a year which ends with this very public, very ringing insistence that there is continuity as well as rupture. And even though it's obvious that William's rule depends on mailed force, that's what all those soldiers are doing outside the Abbey, it does also depend on him showing respect for the history and the traditions of his new kingdom. Because it's that history, it's those traditions that give him his status as a consecrated king. If he dumps on them, then that status means nothing. For William himself, clearly a very difficult balance to strike. And I don't think that we can really finish an account of 1066, this remarkable year, without looking at how in the years that followed 1066, William
征服之年。但这也是以一种公开且强烈的方式宣告：历史既有断裂，也有延续。尽管显而易见，威廉的统治依赖于铁腕武力——这也是所有那些士兵守在修道院外的原因——但它同样依赖于他对新王国历史与传统的尊重。正是这些历史和传统赋予了他受膏君主的地位。如果他践踏这些，那么这种地位将毫无意义。对威廉本人而言，这显然是一个极难把握的平衡。我认为，如果我们不看看1066年之后的岁月中威廉是如何行动的，就无法真正为1066年这个非凡之年画上句号。
did try to strike a balance between his role as conqueror and as anointed king. Brilliant. Let's do that after the break, Tom. So come back after the break to find out how William strikes the balance and ends up ruling his kingdom. After Pentecost, the king travelled about so as to come to Salisbury at Lammas, and there his councillors came to him and all the people occupying land who were of any account over all England, whosoever's vassals they might be, and they all submitted to him and swore oaths of allegiance to him that they would be faithful to him against all other men. That was the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle which was still going after the Norman conquest and is describing an event on the 1st of August 1086. So we have moved on, we've jumped forward in time two
确实试图在他的征服者角色和受膏君王的角色之间取得平衡。太精彩了。汤姆，我们在中场休息后再接着讲。所以休息过后，大家回来听听威廉是如何平衡这两者，并最终统治他的王国的。五旬节之后，国王四处巡游，以便在拉马斯节赶到索尔兹伯里。在那里，他的谋臣们以及全英格兰所有占有土地、举足轻重的人，无论他们是谁的封臣，都来到他面前。他们全都向他臣服，并向他宣誓效忠，承诺在对抗所有人时都对他忠心耿耿。这是《盎格루-撒克逊编年史》中的记载，该书在诺曼征服后仍在继续编写，它描述的是1086年8月1日发生的一件事。所以我们已经向前推进了，时间向前跨越了两个
decades since that tragic year when William of Normandy became King of the English people. So 20 years on this is a good point for us to stop the narrative and to say, what's happened in the intervening period? How deep and how profound has the rupture in English history really been? So Tom, why that scene in particular? And why that scene in particular? Well, partly it's set in Salisbury. So always good to get Wiltshire and the Salisbury area into the podcast. But also because this is a key moment in understanding what has happened to England and how William's regime is functioning. And I think we can begin by trying to work out what has changed by imagining
十年，自诺曼底的威廉成为英格兰人民之王的那个悲惨年份算起。因此，20年过去了，这是一个让我们暂停叙事的好时机，我们可以问问：在此期间发生了什么？英格兰历史上的断裂究竟有多深、多剧烈？那么，汤姆，为什么偏偏是这个场景？而且为什么偏偏是这个场景？嗯，部分原因是因为它设定在索尔兹伯里。所以把威尔特郡和索尔兹伯里地区写进播客总是很好的。但也是因为这是理解英格兰发生了什么以及威廉政权如何运作的关键时刻。我想我们可以通过想象来弄清楚什么发生了改变
that we are riding with the great crowds of landowners who have been summoned to Salisbury and are flocking from all corners of the kingdom. And as you know, if we imagine ourselves riding with them, we could look around and see who, you know, what do these landowners look like? Well, they don't have mustaches. They don't have long hair. Lots of them are wearing their hair in a fashion that derives ultimately from hipsters in Aquitaine in the south of France. So they have a kind of floppy fringe and the back of the head shaved. And this marks them out as Normans, not as English. And why is it that there are no English? Why is it that all the landowners are Norman?
我们正与被召唤到索尔兹伯里、从王国各地蜂拥而至的大群地主一起骑马前行。正如你所知，如果我们想象自己和他们一起骑马，我们可以环顾四周，看看是谁，你知道，这些地主长什么样？嗯，他们没有胡子。他们没有长发。许多人的发型最终源自法国南部阿基坦的嬉皮士。所以他们有一种软塌塌的前刘海，后脑勺剃光了。这标志着他们是诺曼人，而不是英格兰人。为什么没有英格兰人呢？为什么所有的地主都是诺曼人？
And we get an answer from Henry of Huntingdon, this Anglo-Norman historian, so like William of Marmorsby writing in the early 12th century, about 50 years later. He spells out in a single sentence what has happened over the course of William's reign since his coronation in 1066. There was scarcely a noble of English descent in England, Henry writes, but all had been reduced to servitude and lamentation, and it was even disgraceful to be called English. But is he exaggerating? Is that really true? Okay, well, so let's look at the facts and the figures. So, the great dynasties who had dominated England in 1066, before Hastings, they have gone. So the Godwins, Harold, Tostig, Leifwine,
我们可以从亨廷顿的亨利那里得到答案，这位盎格鲁-诺曼历史学家，就像马姆斯伯里的威廉一样生活在12世纪初，大约50年後。他在一句话中阐述了自1066年加冕以来，在威廉统治期间所发生的一切。亨利写道，英格兰几乎没有一个具有英格兰血统的贵族，所有人都沦为了奴役和悲叹的对象，甚至被称为英格兰人都是一种耻辱。但是他夸大其词了吗？这真的是真的吗？好吧，那让我们看看事实和数据。因此，在1066年黑斯廷斯战役之前统治英格兰的伟大王朝已经消失了。所以戈德温家族，哈罗德、托斯蒂格、莱夫温、
Girth, they all died in 1066. Harold's mother, Githa, who had tried to get their bodies and probably been refused by William, she had fled into exile in 1067 after encouraging an abortive uprising in Exeter. Various of Harold's sons who had fled to Ireland and there tried to raise armies to reconquer England. They've either been killed or taken prisoner and are languishing in Williams' jails. Really the only prominent member of Godwin's family who has survived is Edith, so Edward the confessor's wife, and she survives because she is Edward the confessor's wife. So that gives her a status. Williams claims his descent from Edward, and so that enables Edith to kind of continue to enjoy a sort
吉思，他们都在1066年死去了。哈罗德的母亲吉塔曾试图收回他们的尸体，可能遭到了威廉的拒绝，她在1067年煽动埃克塞特的一次流产起义後逃亡流亡。哈罗德的几个儿子曾逃往爱尔兰，并试图在那里集结军队重新征服英格兰。他们要么被杀，要么被俘，目前正在威廉的监狱里饱受煎熬。戈德温家族真正幸存下来的显赫成员只有伊迪丝，也就是忏悔者爱德华的妻子，她之所以能活下来，是因为她是忏悔者爱德华的妻子。这赋予了她一定的地位。威廉声称自己是爱德华的后裔，因此这使得伊迪丝得以继续在温彻斯特享有一种某种
of spectral authority in Winchester as Edward the confessor's widow. And she had lived in Winchester and had died in 1075, so 11 years before this great ceremony in Salisbury. What about the great mercenaries? So Edwin and Morkar, we've been talking a lot about them. Well, they had missed their chance, I think it's fair to say, to stop William. They could have done it in 1066 perhaps, but they definitely can't by the time that William has established his regime more securely. And 1071, they try and raise a rebellion and it all goes horribly wrong. And Edwin is forced to flee to Scotland, but en route he is murdered by a member of his own retinue and Morka is captured and again is imprisoned and is languishing in prison
作为忏悔者爱德华遗孀的虚幻权威。她曾住在温彻斯特，并于1075年去世，也就是索尔兹伯里这场盛大仪式举行的11年前。那些伟大的地方伯爵呢？埃德温和莫卡，我们一直在谈论他们。嗯，我认为客观地说，他们错失了阻止威廉的机会。或许他们在1066年本可以做到这一点，但等到威廉更稳固地建立起他的政权时，他们绝对做不到了。1071年，他们试图发动叛乱，结果却一团糟。埃德温被迫逃往苏格兰，但在途中被他自己随从的一名成员谋杀，莫卡被俘，再次入狱，并在
in 1086. They were not serious people. No, they were not. And also a man not as serious as his father is this guy called Woltheoth, who was the son of Earl Seward. So Seward was the Scandinavian Earl who had helped overthrow Macbeth, he appears in Shakespeare's play, had died and had left a son who hadn't succeeded him because of course Tostec has. But William had looked after Woltheoth, had kind of talent spotted him, had thought that he could employ died and had left a son who hadn't succeeded him because of course Tostik has. But William had looked after Wolffy off, had kind of talent spotted him, had thought that he could employ
1086年仍在狱中苦熬。他们不是什么成大事的人。不，他们确实不是。还有一个人的成就不及他的父亲，这家伙叫沃尔西奥夫，是西华德伯爵的儿子。所以西华德是那个曾帮助推翻麦克白的斯堪的纳维亚伯爵，他出现在莎士比亚的戏剧中，他去世後留下了一个儿子，由于托斯蒂格的原因，这个儿子没有继承他的爵位。但威廉关照了沃尔西奥夫，有点像是看中了贤才，认为他可以重用。死后留下了一个儿子，由于托斯蒂格的缘故，他没有继承爵位。但威廉关照了沃尔西奥夫，有点像是看中了贤才，认为他可以重用
him as the Earl of Northumbria. So in 1072 had appointed him in that role. But three years later, he's implicated in a plot against William, perhaps a little bit unfairly. It seems that he confessed that he had been approached. He hadn't actually participated in it, but William is having none of it. So Wolfioff had been arrested, tried, convicted and beheaded. So all the great Earls have been eliminated in one way or the other. And in fact, of the 1000 richest landowners in England, so these are all the people who were coming towards Salisbury in 1086, only 13 are English. So the Thanes, this body of the elites have effectively been destroyed as a social order. And there is barely a corner of England where
他担任诺森布里亚伯爵。因此，在1072年任命他担任该职。但三年后，他卷入了反对威廉的阴谋，也许有点冤枉。似乎他承认自己曾被拉拢。他实际上并没有参与其中，但威廉根本不吃这一套。因此，沃尔西奥夫被捕、受审、定罪并被斩首。所以所有伟大的伯爵都以这样或那样的方式被消灭了。事实上，在英格兰1000名最富有的地主中——也就是在1086年蜂拥前往索尔兹伯里的所有人——只有13人是英格兰人。因此，萨恩武士阶层作为一种社会秩序，实际上已经被摧毁了。英格兰几乎没有哪个角落
Norman lords have not replaced the native landowners. And there are barely a corner of England where Norman lords have not replaced the native landowners. And there are some amazing figures to illustrate this. So 200 Normans hold half the land in England and 10 Normans hold a quarter of it. So 10 Normans hold a quarter of England. I mean, this looks like, that looks like a colonial takeover. There's no other way of putting it. I mean, we would describe this as the epitome of colonialism. And a foreign elite have moved in, displaced the original people
诺曼领主没有取代本土的地主。英格兰几乎没有哪个角落是诺曼领主没有取代本土的地主的。有一些惊人的数字可以说明这一点。200名诺曼人占有了英格兰一半的土地，10名诺曼人占有了四分之一的土地。也就是说，10名诺曼人占有了英格兰的四分之一。我的意思是，这看起来像，这看起来像是一场殖民接管。没有别的说法了。我的意思是，我们会将此描述为殖民主义的缩影。一个外来的精英阶层搬了进来，取代了原本拥有土地的本地人
who owned the land and taken it all for themselves, right? And so where have the English landowners gone? Well, lots of them have fled to Constantinople where they have enrolled in the Varangians as Harold Hadrada had done. So that stuff about the Varangians, English Varangians in Constantinople, that's one of the big themes of The Last English King, the brilliant novel about this by Julian Rathbone, which is full of anachronisms and stuff, but is absolutely brilliant on the sense of this as a seismic shock, isn't he? Yeah, so the Normans in that are kind of Nazis. He's casting it as the equivalent of the Nazi occupation of Poland. And I mean, the stories of the English lords who flee to Constantinople,
把这一切都据为己有，对吧？那么英格兰的地主都去哪儿了？嗯，许多人逃到了君士坦丁堡，加入了瓦兰吉亚卫队，就像哈罗德·哈德拉达曾经做过的那样。所以关于瓦兰吉亚人、君士坦丁堡的英格兰瓦兰吉亚人的那些事，那是朱利安·拉思伯恩关于这一主题的精彩小说《最后一个英格兰国王》中的一大主题，这部小说充满了时代错误之类的东西，但在表现这种作为地壳运动般冲击的感受方面绝对是精妙绝伦，不是吗？是的，小说中的诺曼人有点像纳粹。他把它塑造成相当于纳粹占领波兰的情景。而且我的意思是，那些逃往君士坦丁堡的英格兰领主的故事，
I mean, are really very dramatic in themselves. The Byzantines often find themselves fighting the Normans and the poor old English keep losing. There's one terrible battle where they all get trapped in a barn and get burnt to death. And some of them end up in Crimea where they found a city called New York. So it's the first New York to be founded. Yeah, I love that fact. That's a very good fact. So it is effectively a complete decapitation of the native aristocracy. And was this always William's plan? So was it always his intention to replace the English aristocracy with his own men? Or was he aiming to do as Canute had done and try and arrive at accommodation with the native
我的意思是，本身确实非常戏剧化。拜占庭人经常发现自己在与诺曼人作战，而可怜的老英格兰人却一再战败。有一场可怕的战役，他们全被困在一个谷仓里被活活烧死了。他们中的一些人最终来到了克里米亚，在那里建立了一个名为纽约的城市。所以这是第一座建立的纽约。是的，我很喜欢这个事实。这是一个非常好的事实。所以这实际上是对本土贵族的一次彻底斩首。这一直是威廉的计划吗？所以他的意图一直是用自己的人取代英格兰贵族吗？还是他想像克努特那样，试图与本土人达成妥协
aristocracy? What makes us different from, because that's 1016, right? I think the evidence makes it pretty clear that William was not, he did not want to eliminate the English aristocracy. I mean, clearly he had to reward his followers with lands and the death of the Godwinsons gave him perfect opportunity to do that. But he was hoping that the English aristocracy would collaborate with him, but instead they just keep rising in insurrection after insurrection. And so year after year, there are these bushfires of rebellion across England and year after
贵族阶层？是什么让我们与众不同，因为那是1016年，对吧？我认为证据非常清楚地表明，威廉不是，他并不想消灭英格兰贵族。我的意思是，很明显他必须用土地来奖赏他的追随者，而戈德温家族的死为他提供了这样做的绝佳机会。但他曾希望英格兰贵族能与他合作，但相反，他们却一次又一次地起义反抗。因此，年复一年，英格兰各地都燃起了叛乱的野火，年复一年
year, brutal man that he is, William stamps them out. And it's not just the native aristocracy who suffer terribly from this process. So lots of the, uh, of the peasantry in England suffer as well. And the most notorious example of this, um, is a series of campaigns that were waged in Northumbria, Southern Northumbria in the winter of 1069 to 70, which is remembered as the harrying of the north. Very, very notorious, kind of mass destruction, mass looting, the deliberate targeting of food supplies, so that over the course of the winter, maybe 150,000 people may have died of starvation, 80,000 oxen. These are the kind of the likely figures.
年，身为冷酷之人的威廉将它们残酷镇压。不仅是本土贵族在这场进程中遭受了惨烈的打击。英格兰的许多农民也同样遭殃。其中最臭名昭著的例子，就是1069年到1070年冬天在诺森布里亚、南诺森布里亚展开的一系列军事行动，人们将其铭记为“哈里诺森布里亚”事件（即对北方的残酷蹂躏）。极其臭名昭著，可以说是大规模破坏、大规模掠夺，蓄意针对粮食供应，以至于在那个冬天过去时，大约有15万 人可能死于饥荒，8万头公牛死亡。这些是大致的数字。
And even William's admirers were shocked. So to quote Alderick Fetalis, famous, famous passage, he wrote, my narrative has frequently had occasion to praise William. But for this act which condemned the innocent and guilty alike to die by slow starvation, I cannot commend him. For when I think of helpless children, young men in the prime of life, and hoary greybeards perishing alike of hunger, I am so moved to pity that I would rather lament the grief and sufferings of the wretched people than make a vain attempt to flatter the perpetrator of such infamy." So that's punchy stuff. It is punchy and it's not my normal thing to sort of defend William, but I'm reminded of the thing we talked about with Harold Hardrada in Norway. Remember when he was chastising the farmers of the uplands who had not paid their taxes?
甚至威廉的崇拜者也感到震惊。引用奥德里克·维塔利斯的一段名篇，他写道：“我的叙事屡次有机会赞美威廉。但对于这一行径——它将无辜者和有罪者一视同仁地判处缓慢的饥饿死亡——我无法赞美他。因为当我想到无辜的儿童、正值壮年的青年以及满头银发的老人同样死于饥饿时，我是如此地心生怜悯，以至于我宁愿哀叹那些不幸之人的悲伤与苦难，也不愿去对这种暴行的施暴者进行无谓的奉承。”这段话很有冲击力。确实很有冲击力，而且为威廉辩护并不是我一贯的风格，但这让我想起了我们谈论挪威的哈罗德·哈德拉达时说过的事。还记得他斥责那些没有纳税的高地农民吗？
And maybe you could argue this is simply what a ruthless 11th century king does when he's, you know, it's part of the assertion of royal authority. does when he's, you know, it's part of the assertion of royal authority. You know, when you've got the emergence of stronger and stronger kingdoms and you've got kings who are serious people as Harold Hardrada and William the Conqueror clearly were, and you know, you step out of line and they will, I mean, they will kill you. Well, the other thing, and this again is a contrast with Harold Hardrada or indeed with Canute, is that the harrying of entire populations, which Harold Hardrada absolutely had done, is not the only thing that William can do to secure his rule over England. Because of course, William comes as the representative of this new military culture that is hugely investing in the construction of castles. So again,
也许你可以争辩说，这正是一个冷酷的11世纪国王在面临这种情况时会做的事，你知道，这是宣示王权的一部分。你知道，当更强大、更稳固的王国崛起，当你拥有像哈罗德·哈德拉达和征服者威廉这样雷厉风行的国王时，你知道，如果你敢出格，他们就会——我的意思是，他们会杀了你。嗯，另一件事——这再次与哈罗德·哈德拉达或克努特形成了对比——就是对整个人群进行残酷蹂躏（而哈罗德·哈德拉达绝对干过这事），并不是威廉巩固对英格兰统治的唯一手段。因为当然，威廉代表着一种极力投资于城堡建设的新军事文化而来。所以再次
let's go back to imagining that we're traveling with the Norman landowners to this great assembly convened by William in Salisbury on the 1st of August 1086. And what would we see ahead of us? So we are not those who know Salisbury, now the town is down by the water meadows where the great cathedral with its tall spire stands. There's nothing there at this point. Salisbury is a great Iron Age hill fort at the place that is now known as Old Seram. And it had been re-fortified by Ethelred and he'd set a mint up there. So it was a fortified point for the Anglo-Saxon kings. But William has inevitably made it even more impregnable. He's built a massive modern bailey right in the centre of Old Seram and it is
让我们回到这样的想象中：我们正与诺曼地主一起，前往威廉于1086年8月1日在索尔兹伯里召集的这场盛大集会。我们前方会看到什么？所以我们并非那些了解索尔兹伯里的人，如今该镇位于水草丰美的低地，宏伟的大教堂及其高耸的尖顶就伫立在那里。此时此刻那里什么也没有。索尔兹伯里是一座巨大的铁器时代山顶堡垒，位于现在被称为老萨勒姆的地方。埃塞尔雷德曾对其进行过重新加固，并在那里设立了一个造币厂。因此，它是盎格鲁-撒克逊国王的一个防御要塞。但威廉不可避免地使之更加易守难攻。他在老萨勒姆的正中央建造了一座宏大的现代内堡，并且
ruled directly by the king. So we've mentioned the Norman landowners, but by far the largest landowner is William himself. So huge, huge direct control over vast arrays of estates and the fortifications. And Salisbury is one of them, Windsor is another, the Tower of London, another still royal fortresses to this day. But William of course is not the only castle builder, pretty much every Norman landowner is building them. And of course they're doing this because they're a tiny minority surrounded by exceedingly hostile natives. And the fact that they are able to protect themselves in these fortifications, I mean, that sets them apart from, say, the Viking warlords who had done this before and who very rapidly had kind of merged into the
由国王直接统治。所以我们提到了诺曼地主，但至今为止最大的地主是威廉本人。因此，他对大片庄园和防御工事拥有极其巨大的直接控制权。索尔兹伯里是其中之一，温莎是另一个，伦敦塔至今仍是另一座皇家堡垒。但威廉当然不是唯一的城堡建造者，几乎每个诺曼地主都在建造城堡。当然，他们这么做是因为他们是一群被极其敌视的本地人包围的极少数群体。他们能够在这些防御工事中保护自己这一事实，我的意思是，这使他们区别于那些曾经这样做并很快融入其中的维京军阀。
mass of the English who surround them. This is not the case with these Norman landowners. They are very obviously physically separate from the people they're ruling because they're surrounded by these ramparts. And this is recognised by the English themselves straight away. So the entry for 1066 in the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle, it recorded how Norman warlords built castles far and wide throughout this country and distressed the wretched folk and always after that it grew much worse. May the end be good when God wills." But here's a thing. So visitors to a major English town and what would have been a major medieval town, if they go today, there are actually two structures that will often dominate the town. So one will be the castle or the ruins of the castle, but the other is often obviously the cathedral
包围他们的英格兰大众。这些诺曼地主可不是这样。他们在肉体上与他们所统治的人民明显隔绝，因为他们被这些城墙包围着。英格兰人自己马上就意识到了这一点。因此，《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》在1066年的条目中记录了诺曼军阀如何在全国各地建造城堡并使穷苦人民叫苦不迭，而且自那以后情况总是变得更糟。“愿上帝旨意带来美好的结局吧。”但这里有个问题。所以，如果游客去往一个主要的英格兰城镇——而且本该是一个主要的中世纪城镇——如果他们今天去的话，实际上通常会有两个建筑俯瞰着整个城镇。一个将是城堡或城堡的废墟，但另一个往往显而易见是大教堂
or a big church. And that's the other side of this, isn't it? So it's partly military power, but there's also, as you've described so often, a kind of spiritual power. So there's a religious dimension to this conquest as well. There is. And so again, if you're coming up to Old Seram, you're coming up to Salisbury, you'd see the castle, but you would also see a half completed cathedral, which is massive. Workmen have been toiling away for pretty much a decade. And as you say, it's part of a huge programme of church building in England that is completely unprecedented in the scale of its ambition. And most of the medieval cathedrals that still dominate English cathedral towns to this day were almost all of them either founded or actually constructed in the main in the immediate wake of the conquest
或一座大教堂。这也是硬币的另一面，不是吗？所以这部分是军事力量，但正如你经常描述的那样，还有一种精神力量。所以这场征服也有一个宗教维度。确实如此。所以同样地，如果你走向老萨勒姆，走向索尔兹伯里，你会看到城堡，但你也会看到一座建造了一半的大教堂，它体量庞大。工人们已经辛勤劳作了差不多十年。正如你所说，它是英格兰大规模教堂建设宏伟计划的一部分，其雄心壮志的规模是史无前例的。如今仍然主导着英格兰大教堂城镇的大多数中世纪大教堂，几乎全都是在征服后不久或在其后大约一代人的时间内建立的，或者主要是在那个时期建造的。
or generation or so after it. And of the Anglo-Saxon minsters, I mean, barely a brick of those was left standing. And the Norman cathedrals that were built on the site of the Anglo-Saxon cathedrals, I mean, they don't just obliterate the memory of the Anglo-Saxon church, but they establish an imprint on the country that was designed to last. And in fact, the cathedral that's being built on Old Serum, I mean, it's one of the very few examples of a cathedral over the course of the Middle Ages that gets replaced in its entirety, because ultimately people decide that Old Serum is too inconvenient, and so they move down to the lowlands below Old Serum, which is where Salisbury Cathedral as it stands today is then kind of rebuilt.
在盎格鲁-撒克逊修道院中，我的意思是，几乎连一块砖都没有留下来。那些在盎格鲁-撒克逊大教堂旧址上建造的诺曼大教堂，我的意思是，它们不仅抹去了盎格鲁-撒克逊教会的记忆，而且在这个国家留下了旨在持久的印记。事实上，正在老萨勒姆建造的大教堂，我的意思是，它是中世纪时期极少数被完全拆除重建的大教堂之一，因为人们最终认为老萨勒姆太不方便了，于是他们搬到了老萨勒姆下方的低地，也就是如今耸立的索尔兹伯里大教堂重建的地方。
So this programme of church building is then kind of rebuilt. So this program of church building is the kind of the physical expression, as you said, of a kind of great revolution in the affairs of the English church more broadly. And so just as the aristocracy, the English aristocracy has been eliminated, so too have English bishops been removed from the commanding heights of the church. And in fact, by 1086, you have only a single English bishop still in office. And the justification for this is the sense that the English church had been very, very sick and corrupt. So the fact that Stiggen, the archbishop of Canterbury, had surrendered to William doesn't stop him from being deposed in 1070. And he gets replaced by this Italian
所以这个教堂建设工程随后得以重建。所以这个教堂建设工程，正如你所说，是更广泛的英格兰教会事务大革命的一种物质体现。因此，正如贵族阶层——英格兰贵族——被消灭一样，英格兰的主教们也被驱逐出了教会的权力指挥高地。事实上，到了1086年，你只能找到唯一一位仍在任的英格兰主教。这样做的正当理由是人们认为英格兰教会已经病入膏肓且腐败不堪。因此，坎特伯雷大主教斯蒂甘德向威廉投降这一事实，并不能阻止他在1070年被罢免。他被一位意大利人取代
monk who had been talent spotted by William and recruited to serve him in Normandy as the abbot of an abbey in Caen. This is a guy called L'Enfant. If Stigand had been a byword for corruption, L'Enfant is the greatest theologian of his day. I mean, an incredibly impressive figure. And he is the embodiment of everything that is most radical, most innovative, most kind of spiritually impressive, to be honest, about this kind of process of reformation that is associated with Gregory VII, the extraordinary Pope and this kind of reform movement, and which the English, now that they've been defeated, have no choice but to submit to. And I think because they are demoralized, and every time we quote an English chronicler
这位僧侣曾被威廉慧眼识珠，并被招募到诺曼底的卡昂修道院担任住持，以此来为他服务。这个人就是兰弗朗克。如果说斯蒂甘德曾是腐败的代名词，那么兰弗朗克则是他那个时代最伟大的神学家。我的意思是，这是一个令人印象激动的非凡人物。他是这种与格里高利七世（这位非凡的教皇及其改革运动）联系在一起的宗教改革进程中最激进、最具创新性、老实说在精神上也最令人印象深刻的一切的化身，而英格兰人既然已经被打败，就别无选择，只能顺从。而且我认为，由于他们士气低落，而且每当我们引用英格兰编年史家
commenting on their defeat, they all say, you know, this is because of our sins. This is what God wants. We are being punished for our sins. And so I think for that reason, they are prepared to accept the fact that clearly their church was not pleasing to God and therefore perhaps the Aegean stable has to be cleansed. So that is also part of the great revolution that the Normans have brought. And that castle, that half-completed cathedral, they are absolutely symbols of the rupture that the conquest has precipitated. And a further evidence for the scale of the rupture is there in the reason that these landowners have been summoned to Salisbury on Lammas, so the first harvest of the year,
评论他们的失败时，他们都说，你知道，这是因为我们的罪孽。这就是上帝想要的。我们正在为我们的罪孽受罚。因此我认为出于这个原因，他们准备接受这样一个事实：显然他们的教会并不能取悦上帝，因此或许必须清理奥吉亚斯的牛圈（译者注：指清除极其肮脏或腐败的积弊）。这也是诺曼人带来的伟大革命的一部分。那座城堡、那座建设了一半的大教堂，绝对是征服引发的断裂的象征。而这种断裂规模的进一步证据，就在于这些地主被传唤到索尔兹伯里参加拉马斯节（即一年中的第一次收获节）的原因，
so the first of August 1086. So we're told by the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle, why were they gathered there? To submit to him and swear oaths of allegiance to him that they would be faithful to him against all other men. So this is again a consolidation of William's power as king that is radical and revolutionary. The Anglo-Saxon king, we talked about this, did not hold all of the land of England, but effectively this is what William is instituting. Because with this oath, every landowner in England is now accepting publicly that he holds his land directly from William. Tom, I fear that we're teetering on the brink of a discussion of the feudal system, which
也就是1086年的8月1日。正如《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》告诉我们的，他们为什么要聚集在那里？“向他臣服，并向他宣誓效忠，承诺在对抗所有人时都对他忠心耿耿。”这再次巩固了威廉作为国王的激进而革命性的权力。我们谈到过，盎格鲁-撒克逊国王并没有拥有英格兰的所有土地，但这实际上正是威廉正在确立的制度。因为通过这一誓言，英格兰的每一位地主现在都公开承认，他的土地是直接从威廉手中领有的。汤姆，我担心我们正处于探讨封建制度的边缘，那
would be a terrifying prospect. It would. Let's not use abstract nouns. I mean, you'll find it unusual for me to say that. Let's just look at what it means in practical terms for these landowners who are coming and swearing this oath. So what it does is these landowners have gone through enormous turbulence. You've had rebellions, you've had the native aristocracy kind of rising up, being eliminated, being forced into exile, whatever. And so the legal documents that might enable these new Norman landowners to feel secure in their possessions are not really
将是一个可怕的前景。确实如此。我们不要使用抽象名词。我的意思是，你会发现我说出这话很不寻常。让我们来看看这对前来宣誓的那些地主来说在实际层面上意味着什么。这样做是给这些地主经历了巨大的动荡。你们经历过叛乱，你们经历过本土贵族的起义、被消灭、被迫流亡等等。因此，能够让这些新的诺曼地主对自己的财产感到安心的法律文件并不真正
there. And so this is what William has been trying to rectify. And for seven months, his agents have been going around England and recording who owns what land. And these agents are recording two key details. So they're recording who owned the land when Edward the Confessor died on the 5th of January January 1066 and who are the landowners now. And observant listeners will note that that completely eliminates Harold. So Harold has been erased from the historical record. And these records, after this great meeting at Salisbury, will be copied out by a single scribe and come to be known in due course as Doomsday
存在。这就是威廉一直试图纠正的问题。七个月来，他的特工一直在英格兰各地奔走，记录着谁拥有什么土地。这些特工记录了两个关键细节。他们记录了忏悔者爱德华于1066年1月5日去世时是谁拥有的土地，以及现在的地主是谁。细心的听众会注意到，这完全排除了哈罗德。因此，哈罗德已被从历史记录中抹去。在索尔兹伯里这场盛大会议之后，这些记录将被一名书记员抄录下来，并在日后被称为《末日审判书》
Book. And it's likely that that name is being applied to it very, very early on. And it is called Doomsday Book because the presumption is that what has been recorded is unalterable, like the judgments that will be delivered at the end of days, you know, the day of judgment. And what the Doomsday Book stands for is the recognition that there's an entirely new order, right? That there's been a massive transfer of property and power from one social group to another, from the English aristocracy to the Norman aristocracy. And the point is that like the cathedrals and the castles, this is going to last forever. There's no turning back now. That was 20 years ago and it's set in stone, literally, in the case of the castles and the cathedrals.
而且这个名字很可能在很早很早的时候就已经开始被使用了。它之所以被称为《末日审判书》，是因为人们假定所记录的内容是不可更改的，就像将在世界末日（即审判日）作出的判决一样。而《末日审判书》代表着人们对一个全新秩序的承认，即财富和权力已经从一个社会阶层大规模转移到了另一个社会阶层，从英格兰贵族转移到了诺曼贵族。关键在于，就像大教堂和城堡一样，这一切将永远持续下去。现在已经无法回头了。那是20年前的事了，而且在城堡和大教堂的例子中，它是字面意义上刻在石头里的。
Absolutely. And everybody accepts that, do you think, by this point? I mean, there may be a few people who, in their cups late at night, look back to the old days, but by and large, everyone accepts the world has changed. Yes, maybe, although one of the things that has precipitated William's desire to compile this great legal record is the fact that for about a year, William's hold on England has actually seemed quite precarious. And the reason for that is one that you touched on in your account of Harold Hardrada, where you said, is he the last of the Vikings? Well,
绝对是的。你认为到了这个时候，每个人都接受这一点了吗？我的意思是，可能还会有少数人，在深夜喝醉了酒时，会怀念旧日时光，但总的来说，大家都接受了世界已经改变的事实。是的，也许吧，尽管促使威廉渴望编纂这部伟大法律记录的原因之一，恰恰是威廉对英格兰的掌控在过去大约一年里实际上看起来相当不稳固。其原因正是你在讲述哈罗德·哈德拉达时触及的那一点，当时你问，他是最后一个维京人吗？嗯，
actually, no, he's not, because there are still Scandinavian kings who aspire to conquer England. And this is very evident in the circumstances that give birth to the Doomsday Book. So what prompted it is the prospect of an invasion by the Danish King Canute. So this is the Canute, the nephew of the famous Canute, who'd been the great adversary of Harold Hardrader and is still very much on the scene and is threatening to launch a full-born amphibious invasion of William's kingdom. And so William, very like Athelred, wants to know how much money he's got and where he can obtain it from. And he does this in the full consciousness that Scandinavian warlords are still on the
实际上，并不是，因为仍然有斯堪的纳维亚国王渴望征服英格兰。这一点在孕育《末日审判书》的环境中显露无遗。促成它的原因是对丹麦国王克努特入侵的前景的担忧。所以这位克努特是著名克努特的侄子，后者曾是哈罗德·哈德拉达的强大对手，并且目前仍然活跃在舞台上，威胁要对威廉的王国发动全面的人海两栖入侵。因此，威廉非常像埃塞尔雷德，他想知道自己有多少钱以及能从哪里筹集到资金。他这样做的前提是清醒地认识到斯堪的纳维亚军阀仍然在
scene. So in 1069, Svein, the Danish king, had sailed up the Humber and William had paid the Danes off, just as Athelred might have done. And obviously William is not Athelred, but again and again throughout his reign, he is doing as Athelred had sought to do, which is essentially to exploit to the full the incredible wealth and administrative know-how of his kingdom. And so in that sense, the Doomsday Book, as well as being the final nail in the coffin of Anglo-Saxon England, as you said, kind of a public proclamation that everything has changed, is also the kind of the last hurrah of that Anglo-Saxon state.
现场。因此在1069年，丹麦国王斯温曾率船驶入亨伯河，威廉像埃塞尔雷德曾经做的那样，花钱把丹麦人打发走了。显而易见，威廉不是埃塞尔雷德，但在他统治的整个过程中，他一次又一次地做着埃塞尔雷德曾经试图去做的事，那就是基本上充分利用他那令人难以置信的财富和王国的行政专长。因此从这个意义上说，《末日审判书》正如你所说，既是盎格鲁-撒克逊英格兰棺木上的最后一颗钉子、是对一切已经改变的公开宣告，同时也是那个盎格鲁-撒克逊国家的最后狂欢。
And the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle writing about it, I mean, he expresses shock at how intrusive William's agents are. Right, so very narrowly did he have everywhere investigated that there was no single hide nor yard of land, nor indeed, it is a shame to relate, but it seemed no shame to him to do, One ox, nor one cow, nor one pig was there left out and not put down in his record. But even as the Anglo-Saxon chronicle is complaining about this, what it is recording is a measure of governmental sophistication that is only possible in the kingdom like England. Doomsday Book could not have been compiled anywhere
《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》在对此进行记载时，表达了对威廉特工侵入性之深的震惊。没错，他把到处调查得如此仔细，以至于没有一块隐藏的土地或码数土地，甚至说出来都觉得丢脸，但对他来说这么做并不觉得丢脸，一头公牛、一头母牛或一头猪都没有被遗漏而没有记入他的记录中。然而，正当《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》对此抱怨连连时，它所记录的其实是一种只有在英格兰这样的王国中才可能实现的政府成熟度。末日审判书不可能在
else in Latin Christendom, which is why it's so exceptional. And it marks William out not just as someone who is a conqueror, but also as someone who is exploiting the resources of his kingdom far more ably than Athelred, or the confessor, had been able to do. And so in a sense, the strength of his monarchy is a reflection of the very kingdom that he's conquered. There are other examples as well where things that are notorious as markers of William's conquest of England, you can place it in a line of descent from what Anglo-Saxon kings were doing. So the harrowing of the North, for instance. I mean, the most notorious episode
拉丁基督教世界的其他任何地方被编纂出来，这就是为什么它如此非凡。它使威廉不仅显现为一个征服者，而且显现为一个比埃塞尔雷德或忏悔者更能干地开发其王国资源的人。因此从某种意义上说，他的君主制的强大正是他所征服的那个王国本身的反映。还有其他一些例子，人们认为臭名昭著的威廉征服英格兰的标志，其实可以追溯到盎格鲁-撒克逊国王们一直在做的事情的传承中。比如对北方的残酷蹂躏。我的意思是，这是他作为国王统治期间最臭名昭著的插曲，
of his reign as king, but he's behaving as Edgar had done. We began this series with Edgar. Edgar the Peaceable. Edgar the Peaceable, the Pacificus. And is called pacificus because he guaranteed order, and William is called pacificus. You know, those anthems that get sung to him after his coronation, he's hailed as peace-giving, exactly as Edgar had been, and William is peace-giving because he also deals out death and destruction to those who rebel against him, and that is very Anglo-Saxon.
但他所表现出来的行为就像埃德加曾经做过的那样。我们是以埃德加开始这个系列的。和平者埃德加。和平者埃德加，即“和平缔造者”（Pacificus）。之所以被称为“和平缔造者”，是因为他保证了秩序，而威廉也被称为“和平缔造者”。你知道，那些在他加冕后为他歌唱的赞美诗，他被誉为赐予和平者，正如埃德加曾经那样，威廉也是赐予和平者，因为他也对那些反叛他的人施以死亡和毁灭，这非常具有盎格鲁-撒克逊特色。
And yet, maybe we could push that too far far because we do know, because it comes up in English Chronicles and things, that the English, the native born English do have a profound sense of trauma that is passed down the generations because of this. So we could dress this up and say, oh, it's a lovely balancing act and, you know, the, the, the working in the Anglo-Saxon state. But this is a genuinely kind of traumatic and it's a massive rupture for if you're living through this, you feel it as a huge rupture, don't you? And William, I mean, he knows this as well as anybody. I think it's pretty clear that William does suffer a slightly guilty conscience about
然而，也许我们不能把这一点推得太远，因为我们确实知道——因为这在英格兰的编年史和其他记录中有所提及——本土出生的英格兰人由于这件事确实有一种代代相传的深刻创伤感。所以我们可以把这粉饰一番，说，哦，这是一种美妙的平衡行为，你知道，并且，在盎格鲁-撒克逊国家中运转良好。但这确实是一种真正的创伤，对于亲历这一切的人来说，这是一次巨大的断裂，你把它感受为一次巨大的断裂，不是吗？而威廉——我的意思是，他对此心知肚明。我认为很明显，威廉内心确实对
it. So we've already mentioned how he pays penance for the slaughter at Hastings by building a great abbey on the site of the battle with the altar supposedly marking the place where Harold had made his last stand. And according to Orderate Phatalis, on his deathbed, he confessed that he had persecuted the people of England beyond all reason. But it is traumatic. It's devastating, particularly if you're an Anglo-Saxon landowner. I mean, completely traumatic. But I think it is something to put in the counterbalance that the Norman conquest does end up bringing an end to many of the tribulations and evils that we have been describing over
这件事感到有些内疚。所以我们已经提到过他是如何通过在战役遗址上建造一座宏伟的修道院来为黑斯廷斯的屠杀赎罪的，据信那里的圣坛标志着哈罗德做最后抵抗的地方。根据奥德里克·维塔利斯的说法，他在临终前坦白，他超越一切理性地迫害了英格兰人民。但这确实是创伤性的。这是毁灭性的，特别是如果你是一个盎格鲁-撒克逊地主的话。我的意思是，完全是创伤性的。但我认为，可以作为平衡的是，诺曼征服确实最终结束了我们在整个系列中一直描述的许多苦难和罪恶。
the course of this entire series. So Williams Reign does effectively see the end of Viking invasions, of disputed successions, of feuding among rival magnates within the Kingdom of England. There's no equivalent of the rivalry between the Elves of Mercia and the Elves of Wessex, both those ranks have gone. And more than that, I think it's a mistake to see the new regime that the conquest ushers in purely as characterized by brutality and greed. So Julian Rathbone in The Last English King compares the Normans to the Nazis in Poland. I think that is grotesquely unfair on the Normans. I mean, they are fearsome adversaries, but they are also, and this may sound very strange to people, but they are the embodiments of a change in attitude
因此，威廉的统治实际上确实看到了维京人入侵、王位继承争端以及英格兰王国内部敌对显贵之间宿怨的终结。这里没有麦西亚伯爵和威塞克斯伯爵之间敌对状态的同类事物，这两个阶层都已经消失了。不仅如此，我认为把征服所开创的新政权仅仅视为残暴和贪婪的化身是一个错误。所以朱利安·拉思伯恩在《最后一个英格兰国王》中将诺曼人比作波兰的纳粹。我认为这对诺曼人来说是极其不公平的。我的意思是，他们是可怕的对手，但他们也是——这听起来可能对人们很奇怪——他们是战争中对胜利和征服的态度转变的化身，这种转变在接下来的几个世纪里将变得极其重要。
towards victory and conquest in war that will become hugely significant over the course of the centuries to come. So we talked about the possibility that William may personally have been involved in the butchery of Harold at Hastings but possibly covered it up and whether that's true or not is by the by. That it can even be counted as a theory reflects the fact that the age when slaughtering your enemies and cutting them up into pieces, and this could be praised, that this is fading into history, because the codes of what will become chivalry are already making their mark in France. William does not actually slaughter large numbers of magnates. The only one he has executed is Wolfioff, the son of the Earl of Northumbria who had been in rebellion against him.
我们讨论过威廉可能亲自参与了黑斯廷斯战役中对哈罗德的屠杀但可能掩盖了这一事实，无论这是真是假都不重要。它甚至可以被算作一种理论，这反映了这样一个事实：屠杀敌人并将其碎尸万段并因此受到赞扬的时代正在渐渐退入历史，因为将成为骑士精神的代码已经在法国留下了它们的印记。威廉实际上并没有屠杀大量的显贵。他唯一处决的人是沃尔西奥夫，即曾起兵反抗他的诺森布里亚伯爵的儿子。
Edgar Affeling, despite being implicated in countless insurrections, kind of lives through a ripe And when Audric Vitalis condemns the harrowing of the North, he's judging it by William's own standards. The standards that had prevailed in the Anglo-Saxon period no longer prevail. It's no longer seen as acceptable to go around harrying entire counties. You don't think that the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle would have reported it in a similar vein if it had been done by Edward the Confessor or by Ethel Redding Reddy or whoever? I don't know. I mean, the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle reports a lot of harryings and ravaging.
埃德加·埃瑟ling（Edgar Ætheling）尽管卷入了无数次叛乱，却安享了天年。当奥德里克·维塔利斯谴责对北方的残酷蹂躏时，他是用威廉自己的标准来评判的。盎格鲁-撒克逊时期盛行的标准已不再适用。四处蹂躏整个郡的行为已不再被认为是可接受的。你不认为如果这是由忏悔者爱德华、埃塞尔雷德或随便什么人干的，《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》也会以类似的角度进行报道吗？我不知道。我的意思是，《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》报道了大量的蹂躏和洗劫。
I mean, just to quote a really fascinating essay by Malcolm Strickland in a recent book of essays on the Norman conquest, and he observes how in Britain and Scandinavia in the 11th century, enemy warriors were generally killed without quarter in combat or executed on capture, while women and children were enslaved. And any who might hinder the effective transport of this human booty, such as the old sick or very young, were put to the sword. By contrast, in Normandy as in France, the enslaving of captives in wars between fellow Franks or other Christians had become regarded as unacceptable. And in that light, it's interesting to note that one of the most vivid social changes that is revealed by Doomsday Book is the decline
我的意思是，只需引用马尔科姆·斯特里克兰在最近一本关于诺曼征服的论文集中一篇非常吸引人的文章，他观察到在11世纪的英国和斯堪的纳维亚，敌方战士在战斗中通常被毫不留情地杀死或在被俘后处决，而妇女和儿童则被沦为奴隶。任何可能阻碍有效运送这些人类战利品的人，例如老人、病人和极幼小的儿童，都会被刀剑伺候。相比之下，在诺曼底和法国，在同族法兰克人或其他基督徒之间的战争中将俘虏沦为奴隶的做法已经被认为不可接受。有鉴于此，有趣的是，《末日审判书》揭示的最鲜明的社会变化之一就是奴隶制的衰落。
of slavery. We know that the English kings, the Anglo-Saxon kings, were absolutely in the habit of enslaving their enemies. Bristol long before it became a great centre for the Atlantic slave trade was a massive booming entrepot for slaves who'd be exported to the Caliphate or wherever, and lots of these are harvested from England. So Harold at Hastings is certainly not defending the freedom of the 10% of the population of England who lived as slaves, whereas William as king does take active steps to prohibit the slave trade. So William in a sense is the first great abolitionist in English history. This is a direction I did not expect this series taken. Woke William the Conqueror.
我们知道，英格兰国王，即盎格鲁-撒克逊国王，绝对习惯于将他们的敌人沦为奴隶。布里斯托尔早在成为大西洋奴隶贸易的巨大中心之前，就是一个繁荣的奴隶集散地，奴隶会被出口到哈里发国或其他地方，其中许多人是从英格兰掠夺来的。因此，黑斯廷斯战役中的哈罗德当然不是在捍卫英格兰1%生活为奴的人口自由，而威廉作为国王确实采取了积极措施禁止奴隶贸易。因此，从某种意义上说，威廉是英格兰历史上第一位伟大的废奴主义者。这个系列的发展方向是我万万没有料到的。“觉醒的征服者威廉”。
It highlights why this story is so brilliant. I mean it is clearly a thrilling story. We've, you know, we've, we keep harping on that. It's one that extraordinary tales of heroism and sodden through with bloodshed, but it is, I think, a morally complex one too, which is what makes it so fascinating. Wonderful story, Tom, and brilliantly narrated. We've done 10 episodes in total on the last days of Anglo-Saxon England, on Cnut, on Harold Hardrada, on William of Normandy, Harold and so on. I've learned an enormous amount and enjoyed it hugely. So congratulations to you, hats off to you. And actually this isn't the end of the Normans and the rest is history, right?
这凸显了为什么这个故事如此精彩。我的意思是，这显然是一个扣人心弦的故事。我们一直在——你知道——我们一直在喋喋不休地谈论这一点。这是一个充满英雄主义非凡传奇并浸透着流血的故事，但我也认为它是一个道德复杂的 ſt，这正是它如此迷人的原因。精彩的故事，汤姆，叙述得太棒了。我们总共制作了10集关于盎格鲁-撒克逊英格兰最后几天、克努特、哈罗德·哈德拉达、诺曼底的威廉、哈罗德等人的节目。我学到了极多，并且享受了极大的乐趣。所以向你表示祝贺，向你致敬。事实上，这并不是诺曼人的终结，余下的历史还在继续，对吧？
Because you have plans for future Norman episodes. Well, we might as well carry on the story. So we could look at how William dies. Famously horrible accident involving a swelling corpse in a coffin. So that's fun. And his two sons, William Rufus and Henry I are great figures. And then England gets torn to pieces in another civil war by Henry I's daughter Matilda and William's grandson, Stephen. So we've got that to look forward to. There's an extraordinary story of William's grandson Stephen. So we've got that to look forward to. There's an extraordinary story of how the Norman adventurers who we've occasionally
因为你对未来关于诺曼人的剧集还有计划。嗯，我们不妨把这个故事讲下去。所以我们可以看看威廉是怎么死的。那是桩著名的可怕事故，涉及棺材里肿胀的尸体。所以那很有趣。他的两个儿子，威廉·鲁弗斯和亨利一世都是了不起的人物。然后英格兰又被亨利一世的女儿玛蒂尔达和威廉的孙子斯蒂芬之间的另一场内战撕成了碎片。所以我们有这些可以期待。关于威廉的孙子斯蒂芬，有一个非凡的故事。所以我们有这些可以期待。有一个非凡的故事讲述了我们偶尔提及的那些诺曼冒险家
been referring to in southern Italy and Sicily conquered a great kingdom there. And also lurking behind all this, the notion of holy war, the idea that warriors can do God's purpose by felling their enemies is extraordinary story of the first crusade. And that also we must definitely do at some point. But I think in the meanwhile, we've had enough of Normans. So we will say goodbye. We will say goodbye.
在南意大利和西西里征造了一个伟大的王国。潜藏在这一切背后的，还有圣战的概念，即战士们可以通过砍倒敌人来达成上帝的旨意，这是第一次十字军东征的非凡故事。这也是我们在某个时候必须去做的。但我想在此期间，我们对诺曼人的讲述已经够了。所以我们要说再见了。我们要说再见了。
Goodbye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。